[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN:
Hey, there I/O Live.
Todd Kerpelman
here, and I am here
with Jen Tong, who is apparently
using the power of the cloud
to find new planets.
No big deal.
JEN TONG: Yeah, why not?
TODD KERPELMAN: Sure.
So, Jen, what is going
on here at this booth?
JEN TONG: So behind us,
we see Project PANOPTES,
which is an open source project
that includes open source
hardware that is
composed entirely
of commercial,
off-the-shelf components.
And it is intended
to be low-cost enough
for educational
institutions and hobby
astronomers to build
these robotic telescopes
and contribute to the project.
TODD KERPELMAN: And so
what happens once they
build these robotic telescopes?
How are they discovering stars--
or planets, I should say?
JEN TONG: So the
way they discover
planets around other stars is
by combining their efforts using
the cloud.
So what happens is, each
night, the telescopes
will all wake up
and look at the sky.
And they'll get a bunch of
great images of the sky.
And then, when the
day comes, they'll
go to sleep but not really.
They're going to start uploading
all their data to Cloud
Platform.
And from there, we can
combine all the data together,
aggregate it, and
then, from that,
we can infer the existence of
planets around other stars.
TODD KERPELMAN: And how do you
infer the existence of planets?
JEN TONG: So planets are
very hard to see directly,
because their stars
are very bright,
and there's lots of glare,
and they're very far away.
In fact, a star only looks
like one pixel on the camera.
So we have to use some
trickery to do that.
So instead of looking
for the planet directly,
we look for a
dimming of the star
when the planet moves
between us and the star,
kind of like an eclipse.
Or we call it a transit
in the more general case.
TODD KERPELMAN: And
so the general idea
is you've got hundreds
of telescopes, all
around the world, taking
pictures of the night sky.
They combine all those images
up to Google Cloud, which
analyzes them all and
looks for a star that
dims on a regular
enough basis that you
think it must be because
there's a planet passing
in front of it.
JEN TONG: That is
exactly correct.
So we're able to infer
that just by having
a whole bunch of samples from
having a very large fleet
of telescopes.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow,
that's very interesting.
Now, if I remember from
being three years old,
stars do twinkle.
How can you tell that a
star is dimming because
of a planet passing in front
of it versus normal star
twinkling?
Which is totally
a technical term.
JEN TONG: Totally technical.
And that's a great
question, because that's
part of the stuff that
makes PANOPTES special.
Because we're using commercial,
off-the-shelf cameras instead
of specialized
astronomy sensors,
we have to compensate
for the fact
that those cameras are
designed to take color photos.
Because when a camera
takes color photos,
it filters some of the
light out using a thing
called a Bayer filter.
And when the star twinkles, it
moves around that Bayer filter.
And it makes it much harder to
count the number of photons.
Because we don't know
how much are getting
filtered out by
the Bayer filter.
So the way we compensate
for that is we
look for another star,
in the same picture,
that has the exact
same amount of twinkle.
And from that, we can
do a relative brightness
measurement, because we know how
bright those stars should be,
because we can
identify the star.
And that's how we kind of
cancel out the twinkle.
TODD KERPELMAN: And I'm
contractually obligated to ask,
what awesome Google Cloud
Platform features are you using
to power Project PANOPTES?
JEN TONG: PANOPTES definitely
kind of illustrates
that boring uses of the cloud
can enable really cool stuff.
So we are using
some simple stuff.
We're using some of the
simple security controls.
We're putting a service account
on each one of the devices,
so we can control access
to a specific telescope,
can access a specific part
of our storage buckets.
And then we're using
Google Cloud Storage
to store all of that data.
And then we're aggregating
it on Google Compute Engine.
TODD KERPELMAN: And
so the general idea
is anybody can get involved.
They can build
their own telescope.
And they can be part
of this project.
And then, if they
find a star, they
can name it after themselves.
Is that basically it?
JEN TONG: Well, naming stars
is a more complicated issue.
And individual
PANOPTES telescopes
don't actually discover
a star themselves.
It's kind of like a team that
collaboratively accomplishes
the goal.
But yeah, anybody
can get involved.
We especially like to work
with hobbyist astronomers
and educational
institutions, because we
want to kind of inspire a
love of astronomy in the youth
around the world.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's good.
And how would I get
started if I wanted to?
JEN TONG: So I encourage
you to go check
out projectpanoptes.org.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
so you heard it here.
Go to projectpanoptes.org,
and you too
can name a star after you.
Jen totally promised
that you can do that.
I'm here with Sara Robinson.
Sara, what is this that
we're looking at here?
SARA ROBINSON: We're looking
at a demo of our Cloud Machine
Learning APIs,
specifically highlighting
our Video API, Speech
API, and Translation API.
So what these let
you do is they let
you access a pre-trained
machine learning model,
with a single REST API
request, so you don't
need to know anything about
how machine learning works
to use them.
TODD KERPELMAN: Awesome.
And what is this game
that we have set up?
SARA ROBINSON: So
we're going to see how
we compare to our Video API.
Shall we take a look?
TODD KERPELMAN: You mean
like me against the computer?
SARA ROBINSON: You against
our pre-trained model.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
well, let's see how it goes.
SARA ROBINSON: Are you
up for the challenge?
TODD KERPELMAN: I think so.
What are we going
to do in this game?
SARA ROBINSON: So
what we're going to do
is we're going to play a video.
And I'm going to have you
try to annotate the video
as it's going.
And then, when it's
done, we'll compare
the annotations you came up
with, with our Video API.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
I'm feeling confident.
Let's see if I can
beat this computer.
SARA ROBINSON: All right.
TODD KERPELMAN: All
right, here we go.
SARA ROBINSON: So let's
take a look at this video.
And we're going to
play against the APIs.
We're going to play
against the Video API.
So when I hit Play,
type what you see.
[BACKGROUND CROWD SOUNDS]
TODD KERPELMAN: Keys.
Book.
Keys.
A door, books, plane--
my typing is terrible.
Woman, room, lost,
suitcase, goat.
She's still lost.
Wait, no, now she
has Google Trips.
SARA ROBINSON: So we can
skip to the end of the video.
TODD KERPELMAN:
But wait-- aw, OK.
SARA ROBINSON: We won't
play the whole thing.
But we saw about
half of the video.
So we can see that
found 13 items.
Video API found 89 items.
But it was a valiant effort.
TODD KERPELMAN: Once
again, beaten by a machine.
SARA ROBINSON: Do you want to
take a look at the API response
in a little bit more detail?
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, let's
take a look at what we got here.
SARA ROBINSON: So
this is everything
that the Video API found.
So we can actually skip
to the points in the video
where it found these things.
And then, if we want to look at
the JSON response from the API,
we can do that here.
So we can see all of the
different entities it picked up
in the video.
And we can also take a look at
what the Speech API transcribed
from this video.
So this is an
entire transcription
of the audio from that video
using our Speech-to-Text API.
And we can even use this to skip
to various points in the video.
And then finally, I'll
show our translation API.
So let's say you're a user
somewhere else in the world,
and you want to translate a
video into your own language.
You can go over here.
And we can try it out
in French, for example.
You can also translate the
Video API entities there.
So that's an overview of our
Machine Learning API demo.
TODD KERPELMAN: Hey,
did you like this video?
Want to see more like it?
Head on over to g.co/io/guide
to see all of our I/O guide
videos.
Come on, let's go.
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]